and tom brady needs to learn a new
offense clyde christensen the buccaneers
quarterbacks coach
said recently i think what we'll see
here in tampa is bruce aryan's offense
with a tom brady influence bruce wants
to keep the offense the same tom has
been terrific as far as saying just tell
me what you want to do and honestly
there's a lot of carryover from all
these offenses it's just what you call
certain things we're looking forward to
seeing how he can influence the offense
and this is what we expect you know
there was a theory making the rounds as
tom brady's free agency approached that
he was going to be like peyton manning
and want to go somewhere where
basically he walks through the door and
says here's how we're going to run the
offense and that's never the way brady's
been brady's a product of the patriot
way do your job tell me what my job is
and i'll do it better than anyone but
it's not for me to figure out my job
it's for you to tell me what my job is
yeah that's right that's the culture he
was raised in i mean so he he doesn't
know that peyton manning way of you know
adding influence on a daily basis and
again again tom brady could do that he
certainly can he's got enough knowledge
and and terminology and different
concepts in his brain
uh
to be to be that type of quarterback but
yeah ultimately we know bruce arians he
he thinks his offense is special and it
is it's one of the more creative
aggressive offenses in football over the
last 10 years i mean the results speak
for themselves and
you know you add that mike and and we
know that no risk it no biscuit push the
ball down the field aggressive nature
along and accompany a company with
you know
the edelman wes welker type plays that
brady ran in new england let alone a few
other things that i'm sure they'll do
like we we talked about yesterday or the
day before with gronkowski to where i do
think you'll see a nice blend i still
think the meat and potatoes of the
offense is going to be bruce arians but
you're definitely going to see some of
those plays that hey brady feels
comfortable in them brady knows these
type of plays better than bruce arians
and byron leftwich he could teach them
a little nuances about the plays and
they're great ways to get easy
completions and you know brady really
knows how to execute those type of plays
because he's mastered them for years and
years
yeah i think bruce arians has also
suggested at some point since tom brady
joined the team that he realizes tom
brady recognizes by looking at the
defense what's going to be there what's
not going to be there and even though
arians wants the ball to be pushed down
the field
he will defer to tom brady's judgment
that in a certain play in a certain
circumstance the best thing to do is to
fire off the short pass but you know who
is going to be
that edelman welker in this offense we
talk about all the weapons and you've
got chris goblin and mike evans on the
outside you got the tight ends and o.j
howard and cameron brayton now rob
gronkowski's there who's going to be
the edelman for tom brady chris
well i think if you look at chris godwin
first off i would say that's the guy
more more than likely that's going to
pull that off right uh you got
gronkowski running down the middle of
the field mike evans running something
deeper or at least deeper down the field
than a guy like chris godwin and godwin
you know a very good route runner uh
when catches the ball can get right up
field and make things happen so i i
would expect him to be target number one
as far as that is concerned or that role
is concerned uh i think he's the guy
mike i do i don't know i'm just sitting
here too looking at the rest of the
roster just to make sure if there's any
other names i missed that i think fit
that criteria but i think ultimately it
is going to be chris godwin and you know
the big thing too is with their offense
you know the way it looks right now it
does seem like they're going to be in a
lot of two two tight end type sets which
would leave two receivers on the field
one running back whatever that may be so
i think when you just have that set of
personnel in there
you know i think it's god went all the
way to fill that role
and godwin by the way second among all
receivers in slot receiver yards so
there you go but but then again then
again we can't rule out that a month or
so from now once julian edelman is a
member of the buccaneers we'll hear him
say i've had the buccaneers playbook for
the last month like rob gronkowski
jokingly did a couple of weeks back but
either way they'll get it figured out
with tom brady having someone who
becomes that security blanket when he
looks at the defense and he said this
three years ago he's got three more
football seasons of experience beyond
the point where he said in the aftermath
of super bowl 51 there's nothing you can
show me i haven't already seen i know
what you're going to do i look at the
defense i know what i see and i know
what's going to be there and yeah
whether it's godren or anyone else on
any given play he's going to know and
you know the problem though is chris
without having these guys working
directly together you don't develop that
that body language the hand signals
definitely the look you know the
demeanor i mean all the little clues
that become
an unspoken language as to what the
quarterback wants a receiver to do
yeah no i
that's that's gone by the wayside for
now and you're not yes that's going to
be something that quarterbacks and
receivers are going to have to work
really hard at once they do get in
training camp whenever that is
to spend extra time after practice
working on you know conversating and
that's going to be a big thing for tom
brady here you know one you know you
talk about hey his mastery of knowing
where the ball goes and all that stuff
one of the great things and this is
another thing i think brady will infuse
in this offense once he especially gets
the terminology down and really learns
how to speak the language of bruce
aryan's offense and do all that but the
other thing mike when you talk about his
ability to know where he wants to go
with the ball before the snap
you know for the ball of snap is in new
england
this is one of the great things about
their offense too you know not a ton of
check with me type plays in new england
they got all what's happening plays well
all-purpose plays and what i mean by
that is so many offenses in football go
hey if there's two deep safeties we want
you to play this concept on the left
side if there's one deep safety we want
you to play the concept on the right
side right so there's kind of like hey
this works against two deep type
coverages and this one works against one
deep type coverages well in new england
and this was something i learned playing
for josh mcdaniels that i was amazed at
you know they game plan and they're so
creative
that they have plays that what they say
are all purpose where brady can get up
there and just go omaha blue go and they
know the play that they've designed for
the week is going to work against all
coverages and they don't want their
quarterback to be fooled by ooh is it
one safety is it two safety oh wait it
was a late rotation and they tricked me
and they will go no tom no matter what
the coverage is we want you to look to
the left at the ex-receiver and you give
him his time to get open even if you
know the coverage isn't meant for him
and then they're going to have he's
going to go across the board across the
field with receivers coming into his
vision as he goes across the field where
that is another element that i think is
going to be very effective in the bruce
aryan's offense and brady's going to try
to get that implemented because he knows
like you're saying mike you give me some
of those plays that i had in new england
that were all purpose i'm going to get
up there bruce arians and make the right
decision every time i promise you and
you know i i think bruce is going to
like that
and one of the keys is going to be as we
were saying working together with his
new teammates and
none of us have ruled out and i think we
all suspect that at some point they will
get together somewhere especially now as
we see
right or wrong the restrictions
loosening in many states a trip to
montana with all of the various past
catchers getting together with tom brady
at his place up there and spending
plenty of time figuring out how to
connect how to communicate non-verbally
on the football field and what each guy
likes what he doesn't like how he
catches the ball how tom brady throws
the ball because they have to adjust too
mike evans oj howard cameron breit chris
godwin they're used to catching passes
from jameis winston they have to adjust
to tom brady that's all part of the
process
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports